a controversial decision to allow
grizzly bears to be hunted for the first
time in decades in Wyoming and Idaho is
now on hold a judge issued a temporary
order blocking the hunts after the
federal government lifted protections
last year he's considering whether the
bear should be put back on the
endangered species list Stan Bush of our
Denver station Casey NC travelled to
Wyoming to get both sides of the story
these are the Grizzlies caught in the
crosshairs between hunters and
environmentalists in northern Wyoming
there's going to be Cubs orphaned
wildlife photographer Tom mangle s'en
secured one of the 22 Wyoming permits
granted to hunters his goal to prevent
at least one hunter from killing the
animals bears are so special to all
these people this may be the only bear
they get to see their whole life now if
you're hunter takes that bear he Rob's
that experience from literally millions
of people last week two days before
Wyoming and Idaho were set to open their
first grizzly hunts in more than 40
years a federal judge issued a 14 day
restraining order saying the threat of
death to individual grizzly bears posed
by the scheduled hunt is sufficient to
justify a delay wildlife managers are
asking the judge to allow the killing of
22 bears in Wyoming and one in Idaho to
control the population and eliminate
what they say is a threat to humans and
livestock the truth about these bears is
I mean they're very dangerous and they
can do a lot of damage
Taylor Ingham is a licensed guide for
the grizzly hunts he argues that because
of successful conservation efforts there
are now too many Grizzlies in the wild
since the 1970s I mean the state of
Wyoming has spent tens of millions of
dollars to to bring these bears back to
the population that they are and it's a
success story you know that we can have
a hunting season based on the the strong
population that we have now the National
Park Service estimates that the grizzly
bear population in and around
Yellowstone increased from 136 in 1975
to an estimated 757 in 2014 but recently
the number has dropped to around 700
Mangal Singh argues the population has
not grown
significantly due in part to climate
changes effect on habitat he and other
environmentalists want the Bears to be
put back on the endangered species list
the animals were removed last year
predators kill into the weak and the
sick and we don't we take the biggest
bucks in the biggest bears and it's sort
of anti natural selection a decision on
the fate of the hunt could come by
mid-september
for CBS this morning Stan Bush Jackson
Wyoming you know they're dangerous with
such a beautiful I was going to say
they're so impressive yeah they're just
so beautiful I know there are both sides
of the story but the question is are
they really endangered yes that seems to
be the debate and what's the defining
number yeah I mean that's it's really
difficult you know what's is 700
endangered I don't know yeah well no
soon